it's an ambitious Ukrainian military
offensive in the Northeast that is
retaking land and towns occupied by
Russian military that is now in retreat
by Saturday night the ukrainians had
reached a zoom about 120 kilometers
southeast of the regional capital city
the reconnaissance group and the special
forces are already here in a zoom glory
to Ukraine this Soldier said
is zoomed home to a major rail line is
strategically important and was a
Russian military stronghold for months
no more Russian forces in the city fled
as ukrainians closed in
video showed ukrainians also recapturing
copiansk another key supply line City
and in balaclia retaken by the
ukrainians a day before a Top Commander
raised the flag as a sign of victory
today we are completing the liberation
of balaclia the first big city in our
offenses I'm sure this is not the last
City
but the war has taken its toll in the
recaptured town of gracove Destruction
can be seen everywhere
there are a lot of damaged buildings in
this Village it's almost completely
destroyed the Russian servicemen
occupied every third house there are
huge garbage piles in places they lived
living behind ammunition bullets and
other things they use
the World Bank estimates Ukraine will
need 349 billion dollars in Aid just to
rebuild
by Saturday night the Russian defense
Ministry admitted to withdrawing their
troops from Key towns in the Northeast
but said it was an operational
regrouping but many people on
pro-russian telegram channels are
calling it something else a defeat and
one high-profile Russian military
analyst said that their troops are now
in an operational crisis and that the
ukrainians have seized the initiative in
this war
Gabriel Elizondo Al Jazeera Kiev